[Music]
impacts of coronavirus on restaurants
have been devastating from the small
mom-and-pop shop sleeper adjoins to the
big jeans it has hit across the board
Waffle House in his foes reputation over
the years of always opening up after
hurricanes snowstorms always remaining
open as long as they can so started
thinking about it and actually reached
out on Sunday of last week before they
had actually announced they were closing
Friday morning I got an email that Joe
Rogers jr. would be speaking with me
he's a longtime head of the family that
owns Waffle House if he doesn't speak
too much to the media you really keeps
to himself in this is an issue that he
felt so strongly about that he was
willing to open up we've never seen
anything like this any disaster
momentarily for some period of time
cripples some piece of the business and
we rush in to rescue it for the benefit
of the local customers and our
associates who need work but we have the
rest of the system healthy to go do that
there is no healthy portion of this
system today we are 70% down in the
restaurants then we are 70% down in the
work now that means people Alice oasiz
just our get any hours or some are
getting some hours and then
proportionately in the office and the
support thing your your you can't keep a
full workforce if you only have 25 to
30% of your customer count one of the
other most shocking things that don't
old me honestly is that you know if
there becomes a depression he says he'll
close probably have solutions overall
that's pulling other 600 from what's
already closed now I'm not sure are
called really get to a point where this
is a total nationwide depression not
just the recession but that is his plan
right now and again that just shows
House sirree
this crisis is impacting restaurants
right now the restaurant industry is in
a position solely of survival we're not
even trying to profit at this point
we're just trying to remain open in the
week since March 13th we have seen over
3 million jobs lost in the restaurant
industry 25 billion dollars in sales
losses 3 percent of restaurants which is
almost 30,000 have permanently closed
with no plans to reopen and another 11
percent are considering doing the same
thing over the next 30 days a lot of
restaurants are frantically changing
their business model pivoting overnight
to accommodate this newfound demand for
greater takeout and delivery service for
restaurants that can sustain that
they're going to continue that a lot of
restaurants are going to have a lot of
tough decisions to make and who's paying
the price for that it starts at the
bottom end end of the wage earners and
sadly here we had an economy it was
really lifting a lot of people out of
their circumstances historically of
being close to the poverty line or
across it wages were going up minority
employment is at an all-time high and
getting better this reverse is going to
fall disproportionately on the lower
incomes and minorities we're going to do
our best to protect their incomes but as
you can imagine our business is 25 or 30
percent of what it used to be how long
can we protect people and how much can
we protect them and you have to save the
business
otherwise you'll be no good for anybody
you
[Music]